sono berardo
il cuoco di corte di federico ii
vivo a melfi nel castello di melfi e mi
sposto anche in altri castelli per
cucinare per l'imperatore e per i suoi
commensali
vado dritto verso oria ma non mi fermo a
castel del monte perché castel del monte
è una cucina
queste del mondo è stato dedicato più
per l'arte delle stelle che non per me e
io passo dritto
passo dritto vada ora mi fermo su lucera
mando i miei figli di a fare incetta di
pesce nel lago di lesina
mentre aspetto il mio imperatore che mi
porta la sua cacciagione
il mio imperatore ama moltissimo i
piccioni col miele arrostiti
oppure altri tipi di cacciagione non ama
molto il cinghiale la carne di cinghiale
una carne dura e una carne fibrosa da
una carne senza grassi
e non gliela cucino quasi mai nel
frattempo però faccio preparare dei
formaggi straordinari fatti dai casari
di vicino
formaggi come le mozzarelle come i
caciocavalli
caciocavalli arrivati
dalle mucche portate dall ucraina le
nostre podoliche
formaggi di latte di erbe fresche non
ama il pecorino pecorino un formaggio
duro formaggio forte e noi lo diamo ai
cani e agli animali non lo mangiamo
volentieri nella nostra corte
però la cosa più bella che che fece il
nostro imperatore quando portò alla
nostra corte altri popoli
e lido ed industria armi
vorrei di studiare le cucine degli altri
popoli che lui portava io ero abituato a
cucinare cacciagione
pollame arrivarono gli ebrei
arrivarono i musulmani erano altri
popoli o dovetti studiare e per lui
inventare un piatto che poi sicuramente
nei secoli
veniva usato le scapece
pesca pesa l'ho creata attraverso
la bollitura di pesci in aceto
l'aceto nostro quello che noi facciamo è
l'agresto sono chicchi di uva spremuti
con le mani e poi bolliti colak alanga
con lo zenzero con chiodi garofano
qualche spicchio d'aglio
questi pesci o nelle mie cucine le
faccio mi faccio pulire faccio togliere
le spine e li avvolgo in piccoli
lenzuolini di seta o di cotone e
avvolgano uno ad uno
perché hanno loro motivo
il mio imperatore un imperatore magro
io invece sono un cuoco pu lento però
per questo stiamo bene insieme lui ama
quello che gli cucino e lui ama me
stessa ama me e tutta la mia corte
perché gli faccio mangiare delle cose
nuove ogni volta la cucina non si ripete
si evolve coi popoli
io ho capito questo attraverso la sua
cultura e cerco di trasformare i
prodotti in più modi le dicevo queste
scapece
prendevo questi pesci dimetto in taglie
grosse e butto sopra questo arresto
bollito molto caldo pieni di spezie
chiudo con un coperchio e lo faccio
macerare per due giorni dopo l'ho
portata vola condito solo con dell'olio
crudo a lui piace molto questo tipo di
cucina perché una cucina leggera ma
nutriente perché ne ha bisogno il mio
imperatore
perché il mio imperatore quando va a
fare le guerre
ritorno a casa ritorna nelle sue nei
suoi castelli con la gotta perché mangia
solo carne arrosto e io ho bisogno di
depurare quell'organismo del mio
imperatore gli preparo dei biscotti col
miele il mio da che lui piace moltissimo
oppure lo zucchero ma lo zucchero è
abbastanza grezzo è troppo forte lo
preferisce il miele dappertutto sulla
carne sul sui biscotti nel pane il pane
fatte con farine dure farine nere farina
integrale parini di miglio farina di
orzo
questo è il nostro cibo nel medioevo
che io accompagno poi con degli ottimi
vini che trovo nelle mie campagne del
vulture come lele nico o come la
malvasia o come il greco dove mi porto
più avanti verso
l'irpinia
la capitanata è una zona molto bella e
la puglia dall'altra parte mi conforta
con i suoi grandi con i suoi grandi orti
con le sue grandi pianure dove posso
coltivare le erbe con cui faccio poi
delle crostate dei pasticci
è tutto buono in apulia e tutto buoni in
capitanata è per me il gioco è molto più
semplice molto più facile
mi spingo fin verso tursi dove c'erano
gli amici miei saraceni hanno costruito
tre rabat ha né sui nostri territori
una tursi l'attuale tursi una tricarico
e un altro vicino potenza l'era batane
sono dei luoghi dove i saraceni hanno
creato i loro rabat i loro incontri
e loro hanno portato in dono in dono
alle nostre terre
quello stupendo
tutto che e l'arancio il portogallo
ancora ci sono delle tracce di
portogalli antichi sulle nostre terre a
tursi per esempio c'è la spaccia sono
delle arance grossissime che pensano
anche 3 400 500 grammi l'una volte che i
miei amici saraceni mangia un affette
con la cannella e lo zucchero e
buttavano le bucce le bucce riprendevano
gli abitanti del luogo di bollivano in
acqua dolce erano creati il gilet pò che
per non farlo mangiare musulmani lo
friggevano col maiale
perché il maiale per noi era importante
ma i musulmani non lo mangiavano
provavamo paura anche in seguito
dei cristiani che passavano che se
vedevano le arance pensavano che noi
eravamo tutti i musulmani
allora noi prendevamo le teste dei
maiali li mettevamo una finestra con un
arancio in bocca per dire guardate qui
siamo cristiani perché mangiamo il
maiale non siamo musulmani anche se
abbiamo le arance questi sono i racconti
e le storie
che si perpetua nei secoli no
federico ii iii ci portò tantissime arti
sia
astronomiche si e di cultura lo stupor
mundi ma ci lascio tantissime bellissime
e ottime pietanze che noi nei secoli in
questa nostra piccola regione abbiamo
contribuito a conservare
la basilicata è una regione a sky che la
regione antica
in questa sua arcaicità oggi può
diventare una nicchia una uno scrigno di
profumi di sapori di tradizioni perché
ogni piccolo paese ogni piccolo
villaggio come dicevano loro
mantiene intatte delle tradizioni
incredibile leva è legata agli eventi
cosmici agli eventi della natura
agli eventi
attuali oggi anche di oggi no a
basilicata e straordinari perché
conserva queste grandi 13 azione dico a
volte racconto il fatto
questi grandi eventi legati alla
resurrezione
della natura dove noi prendiamo tre
elementi e li mettiamo insieme per fare
un unico piatto che il nuovo il
formaggio e il verde luogo il simbolo
della cosmici ta del cosmo perché dentro
l'uovo ci sono i quattro elementi della
natura c'è il tuorlo che il fuoco
l'acqua che l'album è l'area e la roccia
la terra nuovo si schiude ed esce fuori
la vita
noi prendiamo nuovo lo leghiamo al
formaggio alla toma a casi e di
qualunque tipo di formaggio che noi
siamo bravissimi a fare da secoli
lo leghiamo al formaggio perché il
formaggio il simbolo della verginità
della purezza della cà tassi
noi ci purifichiamo attraverso il cibo e
lo leghiamo insieme al verde il verde in
la terra l'amara terra e può essere il
finocchietto può essere il cardoncello
può essere il piselli qualunque cosa che
sia verde che sia e noi li mettiamo
insieme nella primavera poi il
cristianesimo di prese di portò il
giorno di pasqua quando finì il medioevo
federico ii lascia tante tracce ma tutto
cambiò in cucina con rinascimento
arrivarono altri prodotti arrivano altri
ingredienti peperoni le patate i
pomodori i peperoncini cambio tutta la
cucina noi abbiamo ancora delle grandi
tradizioni gastronomiche che possiamo
conservare che possiamo offrire come un
grande scrigno innovativo sulle nuove
cucine riprendendo il vecchio quello che
avevamo che se per vecchi si intenda la
conservazione noi abbiamo una regione
straordinaria che può portarsi
all'attenzione universale proprio come
il contenitore
dell'arca e cita dell'antico ad oggi le
nostre ricette sono intrisi di sudori
sicuramente ma sono intrisi di racconti
di favole
di quotidianità le nostre ricette
raccontano i tempi così come chi è
cristiano pensa che gesù raccontava il
suo raccontava le sue esperienze
attraverso il cibo il cibo come mezzi di
comunione il cibo come mezzi di
comunicazione
perché la cosa più incredibile che uno
dei primi mezzi di comunicazione è stato
il cibo perché parlando attraverso il
cibo si uniscono le persone intorno a
una tavola si comunicava
oggi abbiamo la ipad abbiamo tutto per
una volta al mezzo dove si comunicava di
più air intorno a una tavola delle
famiglie si sedevano e comunicano tra di
loro si parlavano raccontavano e poi
trasferivano la sera vicino al calore
del camino e si raccontavano e parlavano
per finire la serata con un bicchier di
vino e una frisella magari vicino a un
caminetto il cibo la comunione e la
comunicazione il cibo non è solo quello
che noi mangiava nome solo quello che
ingeriamo il cibo e vita perché noi
quando siamo nella pancia della mamma
della nostra genitrice ci nutriamo
quando nasciamo ci mettiamo il se non
diciamo ciao mamma chavez è uscito come
sta no ci mettiamo al seno e ci nutriamo
più ci nutriamo e più cresce amo è una
volta che è finito il nostro ciclo della
vita di vendiamo cibo
questo è il grande cibo e il grande
ciclo della vita anche il cibo
immaginate la ricchezza culturale che
una regione come la nostra tiene proprio
perché una regione piccolissima ma con
130 piccoli comuni con 130 esperienze
diverse con tutti i popoli che ci hanno
visitati che per andare dal nord al sud
dall'occidente all'oriente sono passati
di qua è un amplificatore delle
tradizioni la basilicata
facciamo della nostra regione della
nostra basilicata una grande identità
andando a riscoprire queste grandi
tradizioni da federico ii ad altri che
stanno uscendo pian piano fuori
immaginate la ricchezza oggi di una
proiezione
innovativa di una regione
probabilmente davvero berardo quando
parla del suo imperatore
aveva ragione quando disse che il dio
degli ebrei
se avesse conosciuta le terre
come dicevo prima della puglia e della
capitanata probabilmente non avrebbe
fatto della palestina la terra promessa
grazie